[Music]
great news everybody this sunday is
juneteenth it's one of my favorite
holidays and i can't wait to celebrate
yay
looking cute thank you
now before we party down let's take a
minute to understand what juneteenth
actually commemorates and who it's for
in a segment called how did we get here
tonight we're going to talk about
juneteenth juneteenth is a holiday that
commemorates the end of slavery in
america black people celebrate by having
cookouts setting off fireworks and of
course of course rubbing the juneteenth
lamp so that your wishes can be granted
by the juneteenth genie or june genie
okay so i made up that last one but you
might believe me because many white
people don't actually know much about
juneteenths now it's not your fault you
were probably taught crt you know
caucasian race tomfoolery
but
tonight we are going to talk about four
popular misconceptions about juneteenth
first that it celebrates the
emancipation of the enslaved second that
white people freed enslaved people third
that it's a brand new holiday and fourth
that it's just for black people now
we're gonna start with that first
misconception and for that we'll need to
go all the way back to the 16th
president and number one theater fan
abraham lincoln
lincoln issued the emancipation
proclamation on january 1 1863 but it
didn't do much to free the enslaved and
that's because it only freed the slaves
in areas in rebellion against the united
states in other words lincoln only freed
the slaves in areas he didn't control
it's a little bit like telling the
neighbors kids they can stay up all
night watching scary movies and eating
candy it's a nice offer but you ain't in
charge there now another date you might
hear is january 31st 1865. now that's
when congress passed the 13th amendment
ending slavery but here's the thing when
that happened many slave owners didn't
tell their enslaved people that they
were free they kept them working until
june 19 1865 when union soldiers showed
up in galveston texas and informed them
that they were free they called that day
june 10th
yeah i mean i love it now they call it
juneteenth but they should call it labor
day because it's the day a whole bunch
of white people found out that they were
going to have to work for themselves
now when the slaves found out that they
were freed there was a huge celebration
now if you think freak nick was fun you
should have seen the after party for
slavery now next is our second
misconception that white people freed
enslaved people now saying white people
freed the slaves is a little bit like
saying that jolene saved dolly parton's
marriage i'm pretty sure it doesn't
count if you're the one who ruined it in
the first place now
not every enslaved person waited to be
freed for example one out of every seven
confederate slaves escaped to the union
army harriet tubman alone freed 70
enslaved people and then she joined the
union army where she led a raid that
freed over 700 more now these mother
will have you believing that slavery
ended because the kfc colonel had a
change of heart but the history they
won't tell you is that black people
freed black people
so
so let's move on to our third
misconception that juneteenth is a new
holiday nope the formerly enslaved
celebrated that day back in 1865 and
black people have been celebrating every
year since we have park parties and sing
lift every voice and sing and put out
our wooden shoes for the juneteenth elf
to fill with peach cobbler
okay i made up that last one too i'm
just making sure you're paying attention
but the celebrations have been huge in
1936 150 000 to 200 000 people
celebrated juneteenth in dallas alone
for over a hundred years black people
have gathered in our finest stacy adams
to celebrate
stacy adams is a brand of shoes that
black people wear when they get dressed
up it's like red bottoms for people who
have the holy ghost
now in fairness
you may have thought juneteenth was new
because it just became a federal holiday
last year which is pretty embarrassing
but honestly what better way to
celebrate a holiday about white people
taking too long to do something than for
white people to take too long to
acknowledge it
i'm sorry man y'all love freedom so bad
but you don't want to celebrate the day
everybody got it okay
now that leads us to our final
misconception that juneteenth is just
for black people not true after slavery
ended the states ratified the 14th
amendment which was designed to prevent
discrimination against formerly enslaved
people but the sneaky thing is that
amendment has been used in court to help
all kinds of other groups it's like when
beyonce puts out a new album sure it's
good for her but it also helps all of
humanity
the 14th amendment has been used to
create laws that ban sex discrimination
and it was the reason that the supreme
court legalized same-sex marriage in
other words because black people fought
for their rights millions of other
americans have better lives so no june
teeth isn't just for black people but
white people
we're gonna need you to be careful okay
because once you get a hold of things we
all know what you do
last month walmart decided to sell
juneteenth ice cream that's right
we've had our holiday for one year and
walmart's already trying to make a
profit don't you profit enough of a
black people well mark dang you want to
promote something promote my brother
so
yes
white people feel free to celebrate
juneteenth but consider it your chance
to try something new enjoying a thing
without making it about you it'll be
hard but it'll be worth it meanwhile us
black people are gonna dance we're gonna
sing and of course we're gonna drink the
traditional drink of juneteenth
the juntini
this tradition is real
well
at least it's real now this has been how
did we get here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you